bello a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video sono fra vj ed oggi siamo
su outlast 2
minchia quanto sognato di pasta intro
parka e va bene onde evitare che questo
effetto feroci scassi timpani il play
demo perfetto maicon chiude outlast due
demo 6 blake lager man a cameramen che
sta lavorando con sua moglie sette
giornalisti investigativi
state seguendo una pista di indizi che è
iniziata con apparentemente impossibile
omicidio di una donna incinta conosciuta
come gendo di investigazione vi ha
portato miglia e miglia all'interno del
deserto dell'arizona in un'oscurità così
fitta su cui nessuno potrebbe mai
puntare la luce è una corruzione così
profonda che diventare pazzi potrebbe
essere l'unica cosa sana da fare un
inizio idilliaco continua provavo
contento di giocare sta roba elicottero
a sono andati in licopene è successo
abbiamo perso il motore delle righe
certo jesus christ è la cosa giusta da
dire e fratello
e bello giocherà sta roba di domenica
mattina prima della messa soprattutto
ragazzi è cascato da una collina non si
sa come sia possibile gli occhiali non
si sono rose vabbè caso sono occhiali in
titanio sei bravo pulisci valente col
dito 10 su 10 sto gioco
complimenti ragazzine veramente delle
camere ovviamente tutto ciò non si è
rotto niente se questo è cascato
nell'elicottero non si è rotto niente a
me è una volta è cascato il telefono 30
centimetri è scheggiato come cazzo è
fatto ragazzi non facciamoci domande
perché tanto non sa se sei ubriaco è
ubriaco ci manca solo questo varrà to
raise your camcorder presterà il caso
che si prevede calmo zio che ti sei
appena cascato lan elicottero evita di
urlare non urlare tyson per chi sa che
c'è intorno
lo zoom presso scrolls crollati il pene
va bene cosa devo fare londra avanti lo
cerca la mia moglie secondo me sto tizio
ha fatto apposta veni qua voleva
sbarazzarsi di sua moglie ma non sapevo
come fare permesso bravissimo olio cuore
non ho capito dove dovrebbe essere mia
moglie anche perché ci siamo schianto
così ho sentito un rumore bruttissimo
venire voglio andare a controllare va
bene così messo capitale non secchio
l'importante ragazzi salve piano sai
piano zio per l'amor di dio
salve buongiorno ha per caso visto mia
moglie e passare di qua non lo voglio
sapere se si lavi la faccia alla mattina
sì perché sento delle porte che si va
bene chi è stato buongiorno non
seriamente ragazzi perché ho dovuto
spegnere la telecamera nel momento
peggiore della vita qua c'è qualcuno che
nessuno va bene non facevo madonna che
stronzate che ho fatto
regola numero uno che ad allenamenti
rispetteremo sempre tu sei sceso e jesus
del cazzo cos'è sta roba più
[ __ ] mi sono caga tissimo era un
corvo regola numero uno per questo
videogame non bussare alle porte cosa
che invece io sto facendo praticamente
in tutte le porte
buongiorno lei non è una bella persona
lo sa non per insultarla proprio brutto
invece qualcuno qui dentro che ancora
non sa non lo voglio sapere andiamo
avanti
mi scusi buon uomo ho sentito mia moglie
urlare non è che potrebbe restituirmi la
sua voglia è per carità di dio poi
faccia quello che vuole c'è una porta
semiaperta
ok a me non devo bussare può sempre
nettamente io no
non fa niente nessuno ti ha insegnato a
essere ospitale nella tua vita
posso entrare permesso troppo qualcuno
ha chiuso e non è possibile non ci sia
nessuno salve
che bello non solo ai ragazzi ma un
quadro così in camera ma anche no è per
l'amor di dio
qua la tipa si è dimenticata di dormire
con gli assorbenti valgono un altro
discorso niente ragazzi qualcuno ha
chiuso la porta però non c'è nessuno
lavora chiusa lui probabilmente non lo
so per aprire la finestra da finestra
quella laida di tua madre che batte in
autostrada e lo sapevo io che sarebbe
successo regola numero due non fidatevi
dei corvi grazie corvo del cazzo perché
i corpi devono scassare la minchia e sto
gioco qual è il problema che portasse
mia per forma e le porte semiaperte sono
uno status
ok non capisco perché anche le porte ci
si devono mettere il suo gioco già già
fa paura di suo san benedetto come ci
sono finito io qui gioca sta roba
soprattutto c'è qualcuno che ha una
minima idea di dove si chiama nelle
batterie mi stanno finendo poi ci manca
solo quello guarda a maceroni batteria
di riserva si perfetto ok non avevo
capito ragazzi
si può sapere chi è chi si muove negli
alberi che mi dà un fastidio che non
avete idea
corri corri corri ci siamo però il
mercato sono finito lo fermi dove sono
entrato non l'ho visto santana sarà
[ __ ] to brutto stronzo satanassi mimì
caldei che fa rima con fa vj 15 entro
permesso no scusate se ho profanato la
chiesa non mi stavo pagando in mano c'è
qualcuno negli alberi e date un'occhiata
grazie cosa ci fa una chiesa di legno in
arizona nel deserto che melo promette
bene sto posto soprattutto la moglie di
gesù sarà mica sangue di mia moglie
questo prego iddio di no perché in quel
caso potrebbe essere un bel problema
sono
sono finti o sono veri presterò e non lo
voglio sapere basta che camminiamo gr
scusate non vorrei farlo però non c'è
altro spazio quindi scusatemi davvero
comunque ragazzi il senso sta roba lo
vorrei trovare prima o poi magari prima
che esca il gioco ufficiale sarebbe
meglio moglie moglie sei qui dentro
qualcuno mi spiega perchè ci sono dei
tricicli sparsi ad minchiam in questo
posto il premio è per investigare che
cosa vuoi investigare nel corso spiega
me e ti butta nel pozzo
va bene sono sono vivo ha il coraggio di
dirmi che sono vivo come fosse successo
mi ha agguantato una piovra ma sono
ancora vivo e devo fare solid snake nei
condotti va bene e il bello è che lui
continua tranquillo come si dice fosse
perché per lui essere catturati da una
piovra è una cosa normale scaricando
pure la batteria regalano al cam avrà
vinto solo questo ce la fai zio bravo
fratello vai vai mai veloce però a
scuola ho avuto un allucinazione a un
tizio appena volato sopra il soffitto
completamente a caso noi ragazzi non ho
capito calmi come siamo finiti in una
scuola senza un motivo mi sono finiti in
una scuola una volta che siamo entrati
in un villaggio di cannibali come
possibili c'era uno pedalato pure sarà
mica il prof di chimica promesso non so
se orario di lezione effettivamente però
io mi sono intrufolato dentro va bene
non ci avete nulla in contrario
che cazzo ri di questa è una faccia di
uno che ride e la faccia
questo è l'armadietto di uno che ride
jessica jessica un carillon spiegatemi
per scherzo ma perché dovresti fare
queste cose spiega mi che c'è in te tra
la situazione non raga seriamente non
l'ho capita sta roba
ho visto una mano che mi passava davanti
senza un motivo prova bene il successo
con dentro un armadio sono entrato nella
magione anche volevo farlo prova bene si
discende qualche a [ __ ] alte cose che
mi spuntano davanti ma cos'è che
fastidio dio mio
c'era una roba non l'aveva
ciro non vale neanche volendo posso
giocare a sta roba ma di che cazzo
stiamo a parlare abbiate pazienza non è
che si può sopravvivere ma qui dov'è
andato due quella jessica di sta minchia
che c'era un passaggio dietro
l'armadietto sul serio non se riesco
mi carica sto sfruttando vi giuro sto
male la stessa sensazione che provavo
quando giocavo al primo outlast lei
probabilmente mi capisce si crede vista
è va bene erano così tanti compiti per
casa anche io ogni tanto reagivo così è
quando le prove si caricavano di
computer
ok potreste stare calmi mentre la giunta
ragazzi e ragazze outlast 2 un gioco di
piovere e di corvi non ho capito il
perché va bene hanno avanti posso
chiedere il perché ogni tanto esce una
piovra dal soffitto
devo per forza passarci di qua non posso
fare un giro tutto strano
dopo la porta accostata al soffitto
fantastico mica così quasi preferivo il
soffitto cazzo mi potresti toglierti
grazie mi dai fastidio e vabbè mi inizia
lo vivo sono vivo corrie velocissimo e
vabbè salve non avevo chiesto la
macelleria però grazie veloce veloce per
oggi veloce veloce mi sta seguendo non
lo so non mi perdevo veloce che c'è una
macchina non era una macchina a casa ma
che cavolo fatto a scambiare la macchina
pronto lisztiano e va bene mi ha pure
accoltellato come se non bastasse sono
proprio morto quanto sei bello genova
sono riuscita a morire nella demo niente
corvi niente piovre niente luci e niente
macchine perfetto mezzo alle parrocchie
di ci manca solo quello veramente io
vado in mezzo alle pannocchie
chissenefrega gara e velocissimo però
trovato una casa scavalca velocissimo
significato in un bidone
mi sono infilati in un bidone gioco
dell'anno a da possono sbirciare la
formano non mi interessa sbirciare sono
contento così ed è solo una tema quello
il problema
questo speciale
se n'è andato
posso uscire o devi venire a farti cazzi
miei zii o io esco perfetto tante
passato non è andato via per niente
grazzolo è mai visto vabbè dai frati ti
prego mi ha lasciato però c'è sono vivo
mi sta tirando calci nel culo veloce
velocissimo giro velocissimo corni fa
qualcosa madonna quanta gente che mi di
rompere i [ __ ]
ho trovato la via da via veloce salta
zio salta al me ne frega niente saltata
ma lì c'è va bene quanta gente però
regala madonna che casino dove stiamo
andando
e vabbè una remata tu muoia per forza
ora i cazzi sì sì sono salvo sono salvo
sono saldissimo gli occhiali non si
rompe un giorno no qualcosa non si usa
contro gli stadi mai sono code futura ma
ha tagliato il fermano zia padre che non
c'è più la moglie mamidevi castrare per
forza che problemi hai nella vita
ragazzi outlast il videogame dove perdi
la moglie etica strano complimenti
bellissimo c'è la demo è stata veramente
una [ __ ] per essere una demo era calcio
è questo erano a demos di graham penney
anzi si gran premi che non ci sono più
caciarona cassoli questa era la deboli
al trust ii spero che vi sia piaciuta ha
lasciato un bel non deve al mondo e
tacciare like qua dovete sfondarlo
laiche cazzo si fumano i creatori sti
giochi ancora non l'ho capito prove
servito invece thomas rilasciato
commento mi piace condividete su
facebook per far vedere video vostra
nonna sera security scrittore ci
invidiavano eva e si esce anche scassato
scommetto che se cade vita l'elicottero
non ti skulls analisi dei ragazzi